our first employment as a team actually
was with the melon Institute we worked
on a chemistry game we did some
prototypes making a chemistry game for
them and then sophomore year we decided
that we could probably start from
scratch and do a do experiments working
with our own names and the way that
people make decisions involving games we
came in wanted to do something like this
project excerpt was there for us we
wanted to look at the impact of guest
social environment on how well kids
learn that's the computer science major
I am I wrote the front-end back-end for
the software I do some of the front end
stuff and content in the game our
teammate Luke is our psychologist he he
actually worked with us early on the
research face and he also helps set up
the experiment again through the
experiment scripts the hope would be
that one day something that something
that's learned from these experiments is
going to be integrated into educational
games educating kids and middle schools
out there
so what we're trying to do this semester
is really focus in on how feedback
effects how much kids learn in the game
but we realized that we kind of made
this whole complex system that the kids
are interacting with and a lot of the
decisions we made in designing that
we're just kind of based on our own
sense as designers and not necessarily
on empirical data we edited our kind of
initial proposal a few times we found we
found assumptions that we made that we
thought were worth digging into we've
met with people who had different
concerns about assumptions with that we
made or things that other directions
that we could take the project it and so
my I guess our conception of our project
is entirely different than it was when
we first proposed it the classic saying
and like product development is you
never finish a product you just ship it
I think the same goes for research you
never really finish a research project
you just present it when the truth is
you're never ready to run a study the
sub just show up and you do the best you
can with all the preparations you
already made there's always going to be
something I didn't prepare for because I
guess that's what happens when you're
doing new research if the main
experiment that we're going to be
presenting a meeting of the minds is
looking at how the feedback effects how
much kids learn they do like a fraction
task to practice learning on the
fractions and then they play like a fun
game in between sections of the
fractions and so what we're varying
between subjects is how much your
performance on the fractions affects the
game you know we're running experiments
right up until meeting of the minds and
in all likelihood will will still be in
gear to continue running afterwards
it feels like you can do this project
for some time now you kind of have to
step back and start to square when we're
describing it to people again and we
kind of had to take a look back I guess
over the entire project and you know see
what the coherent story is the whole
thing there's always a lot of research
going
really big chance to really see what
ever has to do
you